Benedict Cumberbatch
scene one take one.
When did I know
I wanted to be an actor?
When did Shakespeare know
that he wanted to write.
When did Starbucks
make his first Frappuccino?
That one got me Dr. Strange
A true actor only wants to act.
And the reality is I don't know
how to do anything else.
You OK over there?
It's very important to stay
hydrated
It's... the other side..
Where are the instructions?
Great acting requires training.
You have to train hard
to act great.
Are we going to do anything
besides
watch episodes of Sherlock?
Now you made me miss favorite
part so I have to rewind it
to the beginning.
I need to learn from the master.
It won't be easy.
Try the line
Where's my mother?
Again.
Where is my mother?
Where is your mother?
Where is my mother?!
WHERE IS YOUR MOTHER?!
WHERE IS MY MOTH–
AGAIN!
Where.. is my mother?
That's it.
What the hell is wrong with you?
You have to feel... it
Good.
If you want to succeed
you have to really want it.
And for that to work.
Your art must be your passion.
The doctor said it's for sure.
The test came in positive?
BORING!
I mean how are you going to
make that go viral?
Hmm? do a funny dance.
♪ This could go viral, hmm♪
I just told him I have
three months to live.
♪ 3 months to live, 3 months to
live, UMPH ♪
Just go the internet pregnant.
Again! with entertainment.
This course
will cover everything.
You're a snake. You're a giraffe
reaching up through the canopy
of the jungle voice
physicality your a bird.
The wings make you hover
over close your eyes
you don't oppose your trip.
Everything is beautiful.
Hands... hats all the important
shit
Very good.
That's the indie.
I'm a big fat guy who has
children on my knee, Ho Ho Ho!
Usually you see
from the top down.
It's an external to
internal transformation.
Acting is for me
about facing your fears
and confronting harsh truths.
I don't like your face
That's really rude
Your voice makes me
want to vomit.
You're an asshole.
Truth be too much truth. Never.
Ever too much.
It's about pushing yourself.
No... no!
Okay try like this
NOOOOOOOOOO!!!
HE WAS ONLY A BOY!! DAMN YOU!!!
That will get you
a Golden Globe.
Nom.. easy. Do it for the right
reasons.
The only reason to become
an actor is to become famous and
rich
and if you succeed you will
touch people metaphorically.
You don't have to touch people
They might want you
to touch it.
It can get complicated
just it's a metaphor.
My name is
Benedict Cumberbatch.
Welcome to an actor acts
Vocal warm ups.
Benedict Cumberbatch.
Benedict Cumberbatch
Good... good on
so many levels.